all right at 6 42 helping our troops
crushing some burgers some good stuff
it's at sicky's garage where you could
donate and devour Candace Charles
joining us live at Town Square toast our
troops is what it's called and you've
been showing us off some really yummy
stuff over there
yes really yummy stuff and really
delicious mouth-watering beer and you
can get this beer for free yes 3.99 by
simply bringing some comfort food for
our troops you guys people are already
starting to fill it up but they need
more so you can come on down here bring
those items and get a beer for toast our
troops I'm joined by Chad dudfield thank
you so much for joining us tell us why
you guys started this in the first place
and you guys have been doing this for
about three years now right that's right
yeah so we opened up in the pandemic
here in Las Vegas and people were just
really really participative and
supportive of us so we wanted to find a
way to give back and this is a great
opportunity to do that give back to
people who've given us so much yeah so
that's how this started awesome and I
know that other places throughout the
country or other restaurants are also
participating but besides that they can
come down here and try some of the new
menu items and you're also hooking up
the parents tell us a little bit about
that yeah on Monday nights from 4 P.M to
8 P.M if you come in and purchase an
adult entree we give you two free kids
meals okay so we have things like kids
corn dogs cheeseburgers grilled cheese
chicken tenders things like that but and
let's see right next to you have some
wings too there's a little promotion for
that too yes on Friday and Saturday
nights after 9 p.m it's all you can eat
wings for 17.99 so any of our
traditional wings with any of our 25
flavors it comes with french fries also
17.99 all you can eat awesome awesome
you guys are just coming with all the
good stuff including these four new
items you can try out as well thank you
so much chat for how you're doing in the
community and for all the delicious food
and beer of course I'm gonna taste it
really quickly for you guys just to tell
you how it tastes has a look
I was told delicious Odie kind of taste
to it I feel like very warm it's it's a
great taste that you can get for free as
I mentioned by bringing some awesome
items we'll have a list of those items
on our website agnewsnow.com again this
runs all the way until the end of the
month so plenty of time to come on down
find out more details like I said on our
website newsnow.com for now live from
Sickies at Times Square I'm Candace
Charles 8 news now all right Candace
thank you very much of course Sickies
was in the final four of our Burger
bracket